I passed the cop recently let me explain
the situation the cop was doing 65 in a
65 you ever have that then we all line
up behind them one of my parade float
what are we doing right now even giving
them that smile through the windshield a
Hello is through 65 put my head on my
guy as soon as you get off I got a do 85
to make up for the 75 I would normally
be doing right now and even my GPS was
going off it was like a cop wasn't
getting off we kept passing every exit
I'm looking at my wife like what is he
on a road trip with the cop cop it's out
of his jurisdiction is he stealing it
I'm like I got a pass I got a do to pass
that's what I do whenever I'm gonna
break the law in my vehicle I announce
it to everybody else in the vehicle if
I'm gonna make an illegal u-turn I'm
like I'm banging eue
everybody you're ready I'm banging eue
they're ready they're ready I don't even
know what that means for everybody else
so I'm not sure just letting you know
about the door violation whatever you
got to do to be comfortable with that
get comfortable
I mean I say it so clearly that if a cop
pulled me over and I tried to talk my
way out of it I was like oh I'm sorry
I didn't realize I couldn't make that
turn
I read your lips through the windshield
saying you're gonna bang it you that's
what I did though I slowly passed the
cop I'm doing 70 he's doing 65 you ever
do that slow five mile an hour pass oh
god your heart is pounding me in PI upon
it's like walking past a pitbull and
your flip-flops I'm just giving the cop
to look through the window the whole
time like are you cool with this give me
a nod give me a smile let me know you
cool with this right I mean you can't
let me slowly pass you and then you
light me up that's a weak move right at
least give me that to finger wave like
hey take it back G take it back hero
look like I apologize I didn't realize
the parade wasn't over yet that's right
though I just slowly passed them and
then you gotta get back in front of them
you're like and you just slowly drive
off and you know all the other cause of
whispering
you